(Transcribed by TurboScribe.ai. Go Unlimited to remove this message.) Добре, я бачу у нас якраз такі дві
команди є, дуже чудово.
У нас одна команда.
А, одна команда, вибачаюсь, я переплутав.
Ну, тоді будемо працювати лише з однією командою.
На жаль, теж непогано.
Загалом, які є питання, проблеми, незрозумілості стосовно того,
що розробляється?
Так, дивіться, можна вам продемонструвати дизайн, який зробили
наші дівчата?
Так, ну, ми бачили в п'ятницю цістково,
але загалом давайте глянемо.
Зараз.
Скажіть, вам видно екран?
Так.
Так, добре, значить, дивіться, як я зрозумів, це
буде сторінка основна.
Тобто, якщо ви переходите на блог цього нашого
сайту, вас буде зустрічати ось така сторінка.
Тобто це, ну, яких блогів?
Ми бачимо, що у нас є шапка сайту,
у нас є типу бігуча стрічка, тобто тут
може бути ваша реклама.
І також типу мікроменю, як я зрозумів, товари
місяця.
Ну, і ось все інше.
Далі у нас є також типу сортувальник, як
я зрозумів, Monsterpedia, працевлашування, товари, події, зв'язок.
Тобто, щоб бігом сортувати ці блоги.
Далі що в нас є, це наші контакти.
Тобто, як я зрозумів, це буде, мабуть, інша
сторінка, або це буде десь внизу.
Може ми це трошки переробимо, воно в нас
буде, можливо, в футері сайту, в подвалі.
Ну, можливо, якось там його вмістимо і красиво
оформимо якось це.
Ось, у нас є тут контактики, телефон, адреса,
пошта, взіль, туди-сюди.
Далі що в нас є, це Monsterpedia, тобто
календарик з найближчими подіями.
Ми ще поки не знаємо, як воно в
нас буде виглядати.
Тобто, він буде або статичний, або його можна
буде покласати, і у нас будуть такі виділені
у ці дні.
Всякими там кружечками різноманітними, це ще поки ми
думаємо.
Але просто, як накидать, в плані ось такого
в нас буде календарик.
Далі анкета для вступу в цю корпорацію.
Ну, це просто поки таке оформлення, можливо, щось,
ну, звісно, будемо перероблювати.
Перейдемося до корпорації Монстрів, анкетка, надіслати.
Можливо, з'яжемо це якось з майлом нашим.
Ну, щоб нам, ну, дійсно, приходили повідомлення на
наші мейли.
Ось так, так.
А, ну, і це також блог.
Це ще перший був варіант, начебто.
Ось тут немає, ну, цього насортувальника, тому якось
так.
Це поки все, що ми маємо з дизайну.
Тобто, ну, якось так воно буде виглядати.
Ну, виглядає чудово.
Я думаю, що цілком ви можете починати з
програмної частини.
Виглядає гарно.
Я думаю, що воно не мало би проблем
це все зробити.
Навіть з тим, що ми розглядали в п
'ятницю минуло, з бутстрапом.
Тобто, цілком можете переглянути по запису, або взагалом,
що знаєте.
Міся, ще з приводу програмування.
Ми просто думаємо, на чому саме можна робити.
Я так правильно розумію, що можна робити HTML,
CSS, JavaScript, або Python, так?
Ну, або там React.
Ну, загалом так.
Стосовно Python, я ще поговорю з Сергієм Олексійовичем,
можливо, в п'ятницю.
Якщо все добре, то ми спробуємо розглянути backend
частину серверну.
І там я подивлюсь.
Можливо, це можна буде робити на JavaScript.
Все.
Там Express.js бібліотека, вона набагато простіша, ніж
Django.
Ну, хоча в вашому випадку це буде простіше,
тому що треба щось швидко зробити.
Тобто, якщо я не маю досвіду, то в
той момент розглянув.
Так, оце, що я хотів сказати.
Дивіться, мені мої знайомі, які також працюють в
ІТ, підсказали, що є все-таки плагін для
VS-коди, який дозволяє робити вдвоєм або цілою
компанією.
Це плагін називається LiveShare.
Тобто, я створюю, типу, кімнату, кидаю приглашення, і
тут приєднується.
Я прямо бачу в ранньому часі, хто над
чим працює.
Тобто, це трішечки удобніше.
Тому ми наче злізли з того, що хочемо
працювати, забув, в онлайн додатку.
Вікс?
Вікс, так.
Мабуть, не будемо працювати з Віксом, а будемо
працювати в VS-коді.
Але ще поки визначаємо змогу програмування.
Ну, ви наче сказали, що у п'ятницю
це все в остаточну відповідь може додасти.
Ну, хотілося б, мені здається, що джангу ми
не зможемо так бігом.
Тому що я в ній ніколи не працював,
і, можливо, Віталія також.
І це буде трішки, дійсно, складнувато.
А HTML, CSS, JavaScript, хоч я в JavaScript
не дуже багато працював, але HTML мені близький,
CSS близький трішечки.
Ну, щось я там знаю.
JavaScript пробував колись, тому, можливо, буде легше.
І завдяки цьому плагину, я думаю, що це
дійсно можна туди, через GitHub, і це буде
дійсно краще, чим Вікс, тому що Вікс там
багато чого платного, ми так подивилися.
Тобто там є база безкоштовна, але, звісно, що
в платній версії дуже багато всяких плюшок, які
були б корисні, а платити це дійсно нам
невигодно трішки.
Тому, можливо, будемо робити в VSCode, будемо писати
все це, оформлювати.
Тому це що касається програмування з нашої сторони.
Так, загалом LiveShare досить такий гарний варіант.
Ми мали його розглянути, проте трошки не було
часу.
Я думаю, що можемо і в п'ятницю
загалом оглянути, щоб обидві команди мали, ну і
оглянути загалом можливості протестувати його.
Але так, такий варіант можливий, цілком можна працювати.
Ну, стосовно умов програмування, на FrontEnd ви точно
можете використовувати HTML, CSS.
Тобто там загалом можете використовувати і React, якщо
є бажання.
Ми можемо, якщо будете використовувати, звісно, React, можемо
розглянути і бібліотеки, які там є, схожі до
Bootstrap.
А, ну, за бекенд частину так.
З Python може бути досить складно, з JavaScript
будувати сервісну частину досить легко.
Загалом спробуємо розглянути те, і спробуємо, як підключитися
до бази даних.
Ну, тобто, щоб у вас вже був якийсь...
Це було б набагато краще.
Готовий приклад, так, і ви там просто його
коригували.
Тобто, на JavaScript, на Express.js можна досить
легко будувати без занадто якихось поглиблених знань, якісь
дуже такі простенькі серверні додатки.
Тому я думаю, що цей варіант вам би
підійшов, тому що, ну, у вас не так
багато часу, щоб побудувати це все, і будувати
на чомусь найпростішому, я думаю, є найбільш адекватно.
Ну так, і плюс, я все одно хочу
навчитись JavaScript, тому це було б якраз і
корисно.
Тому, не знаю, мені казалось, що це...
Ну, просто зараз на JavaScript дуже багато що
пишеться, від Telegram-ботів до взагалі всього, і,
видно, розуміти JavaScript — це зараз прикольно з
усіх цих частин.
Так, ну, зараз цілком можна і на Електрон
.js розробляти, користуватися інтерфейсами, серверні частини, які зазначені.
Тобто, досить багато чого можна розробляти, тому я
думаю, що цілком.
Я поговорю з Сергієм Олексіємовичем стосовно цього, тому
що оригінальний план на курс був з Пайтоном,
проте, можливо, цілком вийде змінити.
А запитати ще можна?
Друга команда, так розумію, це Олександр Харченко.
Вони пишуть на Пайтоні, чи вони пишуть на
HTML?
Ну, вони пишуть на HTML частину хоча б
коду.
Вони не показували код, наскільки я пам'ятаю.
Тобто, вони робили на HTML2CSS серверну частину, я
не знаю, на чому вони роблять, якщо чесно.
Тому що минулого заняття їх не було, ми
бачили презентацію лише один раз, тому не впевнений
стосовно їхнього прогресу по проекту взагалі.
Можливо, п'ятницю цю будуть, тому що нам
треба буде постворювати нові завдання, приблизно окреслити, що
далі розробляти, тому що у вас все ж
таки є база, по чому можна продвигатись з
програмною частиною, ну і я думаю, що можна
далі рухатись з дизайном також.
Тому я думаю, що ту частину ми також
спробуємо зробити в п'ятницю, ну і все,
що лишиться по часу, тоді розглянемо серверну частину.
Це у вас буде друге заняття на 11
.20, тому можливо більше людей прийде на цю,
ніж на 9.30. Тому я думаю, що
так, вони пишуть на HTML2CSS, серверну частину будемо
говорити.
Тому що звичайно, мені здається, що тільки Харченко
на заняттях і з'являвся, з другої команди
я більше інших не бачив.
Це так.
Ну добре тоді, вже в нас був створений
репозиторій, я просто додам всіх моїх колег з
моєї команди, настроюємо трішечки всім VS Code, хто
буде працювати, щоб було легше, і можливо вже
щось будемо починати робити.
Тому що час йде.
Так, як я значив, можете спробувати використовувати Bootstrap,
ви з ним досить швидко побудуєте те, що
вам потрібно.
Тобто навіть з Monstropedia буде не важко змінити
по стилях і далі просто копіювати частини з
прикладів, або з того, що там вже є.
Тобто ви там за два тисні зможете побудувати
якийсь дуже простий сайт, щоб показати його.
Добре, добре.
Тоді ми все зрозуміли, всі це у нас
були питання.
Я вам продемонстрував дизайн, бо у нас були
там теж питання якісь такі.
Тому все ми вже вирішили і з приводу
серверної частини також.
Тому у нас в принципі я вважаю, що
все.
Я зараз створюю репозиторії, всіх додам.
Ну ви там вже є, так?
Так, ми додавали.
Тому я зараз ще додам інших.
А можна, будь ласка, у вас ще таке
питання, як видалити файл з GitHub?
Ну у нас там просто є рідмі, який
ми створювали, як би його туди видалити?
Бо я щось не розумію.
А, все, все, все, все.
Знайшли?
Так.
Добре.
Там його, мені здається, можна і через GitHub
видалити.
Чи не певно, чи можна видалити через GitHub?
А, так, можна.
Можна видалити через GitHub, або можна видалити локально
і просто створити коміт і його просунути.
Тому я думаю, що такий варіант також.
Добре, тоді я зупиняю.